All right, so let me actually show you the code that I used to do
that example that we just saw, and then you're just going to be
copying this code in the quiz to make sure that you get all the details.
This stuff that I've just highlighted is the code that's really important, and
hopefully this looks really familiar to what you just saw in the example.
So, what I've already done up to this point is I've loaded in my
training data and I've made some visualizations of it.
We're going to ignore that for now.
But you'll be able to see the code in the quiz if, if you're interested.
And then here, as I said, are the four lines that are really important.
So, we have the import statement like you just saw in the example.
Then we create the classifier.
We fit it, using our training features and our training labels.
And then the last thing that we do is we create a vector of predictions,
this called pred, by using the predict function on our trained classifier.
And then to that we pass the features.